we're playing this game here but crazy
let's play maybe
today what opening should we play but
opening favorite play here
maybe scandinavian
okay let's play scandinavian opening but
okay
because we owe e5
okay so e5 is already bad this is
already a mistake
why why is it a mistake
because if you compare this to a french
like think about it logically a french
would arise if we were to play e6 here
and then white would play d4 that would
be a french advance okay
but what is the main drawback of the
french other than the fact that it sucks
it's the fact that the why does it suck
it's the fact the light squared bishop
apologies to french players the light
squared bishop is behind bars
so let's make sure that it's not behind
bars and then the french is going to be
awesome
right imagine if in the french you could
jump out to f5
this is literally a french advance
except the bishop is on f5 but then you
might think well what about the karaoke
isn't the karo khan
this well the karaoke isn't quite this
because in the karo khan you have this
position
with a loss of tempo if we were to play
c6 here that would be a karo khan
but we have the best of all worlds here
because we don't need to play c6
we can now play c5 in one fell swoop
does that make sense
now we can play c5 and one fell swoop a3
is kind of a waste of time
exactly i mean i think we should we
should cancel the french
also i lost a bunch of games there so
i'm very sour grapes about it
okay so c3 obviously let's let's develop
our knight
um yeah knight c6 uh fabby b
let me just make it colder i'm dying of
beat right now one sec
he is wasting his time what is he doing
here
what is he doing here thank you tony
lasagna okay
stop being annoying all right what
should we do guys french players
i give you the floor french players i
give you the floor what's normal here
how do we put pressure on the pawn
pressure
and so on and so on and so on but we
don't take why
we don't want to take and i will explain
after the game why we don't want to take
yet because the drawback of taking is
that it allows this knight on b1
a natural developing square on c3 one of
the
the good things about this pawn chain
why do we want white to keep it
because as long as white keeps it this
night we'll have a very hard time
developing
now you might say well wait a minute i
get that but doesn't queen b6 allow him
to take the pawn on c5 well it does
but that breaks up the pawn chain we
take with the bishop we attack f2 we
attack e5 that's totally good for us
at least for the time being so you
should only take on d4 when there is a
very tangible benefit to doing so such
as when you're winning that pawn or you
have something going down the c file
you shouldn't take unless you absolutely
have to or unless you gain something
very specific from it
now we have a very cool idea here
and that idea does involve it's not the
best move but i'm going to play it
because it's really cool it does involve
taking on d4
okay i'm going to give you guys a minute
to spot this idea it's not particularly
amazing what i will say is that it wins
upon
it wins upon and it's really pretty
and then after the game i'll explain my
logical thought process
who can spot this idea
it's really tough
now the idea doesn't work if he takes
with it with the knight but that's good
for us anyway
okay let me take now i'm hoping he takes
with the pawn so i'm able to demonstrate
the idea yes oh my god strange quark you
deserve a sub
wow a lot of you are finding it that's
really cool tobias crowd found it as
well and arty beer
you take the knight and what are we
doing and now you take the pawn on a3 at
the very end of it and what's great
about this
is that this bishop now will be able to
return to b4 with an extremely nasty
check
if he takes we take on b1 what do you
have to check for there
you have to check for discovered checks
but he has none because our king is on a
light square
that bishop is a dark squared bishop
all right that's a cool
cool idea this might be the computer's
best i mean i actually think it's it's
probably the best
the best move that's uh that's a
five-head idea
and i'll show you guys a game i played
many many years ago where i
set a very similar kind of trap that's
when i learned about this type of idea i
was 1800 at the time
he's thinking i'm going to pull up the
game
right exactly brandon but brandon give
me
give me the fact that this was cool this
was a very nice idea
this is a legitimately nice idea i think
okay
so bishop d3
now obviously he is reinforcing now the
threat of b63 i have one
important piece of advice to share in
this general
area when a piece is defended tactically
such as a bishop that's on a3 a lot of
people what they'll do
is they will leave the bishop on a3
that's a very common source of a blunder
if you're defending a piece indirectly
and that piece is technically hanging
make sure on every move that you either
remove the piece from that square
or if you leave it there make sure that
your opponent isn't
you know creating the threat of taking
it so in this position for example he's
defending the rook with his bishop
which is why we have to do something
with our bishop bishop before bishop d2
now taking on d4 would be a
blunder taking on d4 would be a blunder
because he would recapture on d4 and
after queen takes d4 he would
give us this very typical check on a4
forking the king of mission
also we don't want to do that anyway
because we're not developed so what
should we do should we take his bishop
and then take the pawn is that fine can
we do that can we take his bishop and
take the pawn
arty beer you're absolutely right but i
want somebody to tell me why we can't do
that no we can't
again typical if you've played the
french knight takes queen takes
and he has the discovery on b5 it should
be five check
so there's really no need to take his
bishop he's not threatening to take our
bishop let's just develop our pieces
there's knight h6 and knight e7 let's
develop a little bit closer to the
center knight h6 is fine
but this gives the knight more options
maybe we'll want to go to g6 to avoid a
greek gift sacrifice for example
also knight f5 would be very nice but he
has a bishop here so that's probably
going to be unlikely
and in fact that uh spiel about avoiding
the greek gift sacrifice
that's a must if we were to castle here
we would allow a great gift sacrifice
and it would work
so we can take on d2 and get his queen
to reposition but i don't
well you know what i reconsider let's
take his bishop let's take his bishop
first
and and not because i want to avoid the
greek gift sacrifice that's not the
primary reason
[Music]
and i'll explain the primary reason
after the game because we're a little
bit short of time
now what can we do now what can we do
now
now if we go nf5 we allow bishop takes
f5 that cripples our pawn structure
but doesn't castle allow a greek gift
sacrifice doesn't castle allow a greek
gift sacrifice
what has changed and of course i've
given you guys the hint that it doesn't
but why why doesn't it allow the great
gift
because the queen can't get to h and not
only can it not get to h5 it can't get
to h4 either
sometimes in the greek gift a queen can
start off on h4
on f4 and then it can go to h4
fulfilling the same exact role
but here the queen can't get to the h
file
so these small little things you know at
this rating at 1600
oh his first name is dela monk as i just
noticed that
um that's not good maybe i should have
played a little bit faster faster
but well
yeah mia is playing pretty well like i'm
saying
simon i think maybe like
15 or 20 i'd have a chance against the
15 1600 struggling turtle thing with
brian
so again we we can't take on d4 still
this time he doesn't have bishop b5 but
he has bishop takes h7 in effect the
same kind of tactic
so a lot of people at this point would
consider king h8 but i don't love that
move
i don't think that's the best way to
reinforce the threat of knight takes d4
what i like doing is repositioning this
knight to g6 this puts something more
solid
in terms of blocking the bishop and i
just kind of like the knight here it can
come to f4 if the queen moves
this knight has a lot of potential
energy not kinetic energy it's not doing
anything right now
other than blocking the bishop but it's
got a lot of potential energy
and i love that you guys are suggesting
rook c8 that could very well be our next
move
first of all this is now a threat which
he has to deal with
come on i thought you were more merciful
than that simon what is
what's wrong with you okay so
i know i'm not trolling guys this is a
phenomenal move
this is a phenomenal move because after
knight takes d4
knight takes d4 queen takes d4 but i
think i out calculated him what's his
idea
what is his idea at the end of that line
he wants to go h5 okay why is that good
because if we move our knight
and he's going to have bishop takes h7
check but let's not despair if we
look at that position very very
carefully after 94 knight d4 queen d4h5
can anybody spot a resource that black
has using that knight on g6
to do something very interesting
no we don't want to go h5 we can take
we can take but after h5 in that final
position a very difficult move
is available to us and that is queen f4
we can move our queen
using the knight as the defender
repositioning our queen
offering a queen shirt and if he moves
this queen then we can move our knight
if i've calculated this correctly we
have four
now he can play rook queen c2 which
builds a little battery against h7 now
that's not that scary we can take on e5
but in addition as you're indicating we
can go right rook ac
the reason we don't go knight f4 is
because it blunders the queen
knight f4 bishop h7 and queen takes d4
and if you think ah well i can fork him
in the end
remember he's got a rook on e1 defending
it too i think some some of you might
have missed that
unconventional the 15 months thank you
that's a nice move is the knight not
trapped in the end no we've got e7 and
e5
we've got we've got plenty of squares no
no problem
my opponent is playing very well though
he's his calculation has been excellent
we've just out calculated him a little
bit
but i've been playing really good chess
myself i think
our our accuracy in this game if we can
keep this going is going to be good
it has to be down keep us exactly
okay guys if it's on f4 the reason
the knight isn't trapped is because
we're attacking the bishop and the pawn
on h5 and we can carve out a square for
the knight you know he can go d4
worse comes to worse and reposition the
knight on d5 he does go
queen to c2 now
which rook do we want to get to c8 let's
consider that question we want to go
rook fc
we want to make an intermediate move
which way
should we go both rooks are fine
i would say but i like the concept of
this rook being a protector of licking
eye roll i don't really want to go with
the f
rook not because there's anything
inherently wrong with it because i'm a
little bit worried about leaving my king
kind of open like this if that makes
sense so it's more of an intuitive
choice
it's more of an intuitive choice that
the benefit of going rook fca
would have been that if he goes queen b3
and then takes the spawn the pawn on a7
will be protected
here the pawn does not protect you queen
e2 is correct we got to move our knight
back
i'm kind of regretting this though we
could have taken the pawn on e5
i think i should have done that knight
takes c5 bishop takes h7 king h8
that was essential i honestly hoped he
wouldn't play queen e2 but this is still
good for us
now we're two puns up black is winning
we just gotta
consolidate make sure he doesn't whip up
any counter play he's probably gonna go
here would be my guess
if i had to guess i've never guessed a
move though before or anything for that
map
god of chess while he's playing like one
okay yeah so gaines is absolutely right
we gotta drop our queen back why did i
go queen g5
why didn't i go queen d4 because queen
d4 would have walked into what nasty
little move
could somebody explain to me why i
didn't go queen before why choose g5
because queen d4 would have walked into
either queen d2 but more so rook b to d
one rook b to d one
centralizing his rook and again i don't
want anything to do with these
discovered attacks and discover checks
so b4 now mental note whenever a pawn is
pushed like this
take five seconds and determine which
squares have been weakened as a
consequence
and in this particular position we can
occupy that square immediately
immediately
as walter brown used to say immediately
we can
look to c3 sinking the rook into that
square making contact with the bishop
potentially preparing to double the
rooks the knight can come out to f5
again we can see how much potential
energy our pieces are having
but we gotta act pretty fast
okay b5 so
one thing to note he might want to play
rook a1 and then we will have a hard
time defending this pawn
so i think we don't necessarily have
time to double rooks
i think we need to go very directly for
a kingside attack
so what what is that what does that
entail
what move does that entail
yeah i did play walter unfortunately he
passed away but
i had the honor of playing him yeah
let's go and add f5
let's get the knight involved now he can
trade
but that's good for us that simplifies
the position where two pawns up
and after queen takes f5 we then could
reposition the rook to c2
second rank equals good if he doesn't do
anything rook to b4 wow that's a really
that's a good looking move but it isn't
actually good
to my understanding because we have a
little bit of a tactic
now as artibian man you're sharp today
knight takes g3 is absolutely right
absolutely right and after f takes g3
some genius put their rook on c3
and after queen takes g3 we check the
king and fork the rook we're four pawns
up there and we win back the bishop
now i guess he wants to play queen g4
but then we trade queens with three
pawns up
with a completely winning end game
not to do my own horn but if we can keep
this going well i want to check my
accuracy in this game
now start thinking about queen g4 start
asking yourself if you have to take the
queen
or might there be ways to win the game
even faster after queen g4
just as a quick you know just to keep
everybody tactically involved
queen g4 do you have to take the queen
can anybody spot an alternative
already beer i feel like you're in a
tactical role you'll spot this move nice
prime suspect sees it queen to d2 lose
pieces drop off
we can move the queen to d2 attack the
rook
and his threats against our king are
non-existent
h6 may look scary but we can always meet
that with g6
if that makes sense the accuracy will be
higher than the internet speed i don't
know
i don't know if anything's possible if
anything could be higher than the
internet speed
but oh but it doesn't quite work i just
noticed something myself
after queen g4 queen to d2 and this is
really complicated he's got rook to d1
attacking the queen i'll show that after
the game he doesn't do it queen takes g3
and this is gonna be pretty
straightforward okay queen g2 what do we
do do we take the queen and take the
bishop
even though we've got a minute you can
take five ten seconds and make sure
you find the most accurate continuation
because that'll pay itself off
if you do find the most accurate
continuation looking
not no tunnel version here you notice
the rook is hanging nice
and now of course we check to make sure
there's no mate threats there
okay is there anything there no there
isn't we can very safely take the bishop
also notice that this pawn hangs with
check as does this rook
so if he goes rook to g4 here it's not
too late to blunder g6 would have been a
pretty big mistake
now before i take on e5 and win to
unlock that who can tell me why
g6 hghg that's the fatal miss no
fatal mistake it's a draw why is that a
big mistake
if we go g6 and then takes and take back
he's got perpetual he can sack the
remaining rook
fg in a very typical perpetual right
queen h6 queen g6
i'm sure everybody's seen that before so
we take the pawn we defend the other
pawn
and we check the king the game is over
either he has to get checkmated
basically
or he has to trade you know allow the
trade of everything
so do you want check of course forcing
him to give up his queen
and again we can take the queen but take
five seconds here find the most accurate
move don't let him breathe
don't let him you know don't let him
flag you
boom queen takes h5
and queen takes g4 and the game is over
absolute gigger chad
yeah take the queen
and we don't have mate in one but we do
have i'm trying to find mid and two here
check we can give made in three
and who sees the mate who sees the mate
before
my time runs out it's queen g3 yeah
okay nice queen g3 all right
let's check the accuracy i feel like
this is the one time i do want to flex
this was a really nice game i'm pumped
drum roll please and
yeah 95.5 that was okay that was i was
hoping for for 97 or 98 but it's fine
um it'll do okay
that's lower than the internet speed
that's right about the internet speed if
you add a zero
okay so we tried to play a scandi and
failed to go z5
and of course bishop f5 leads to
basically an improved fringe
um so d4 e6 again
comparison is a very good way to
understand these kinds of positions
so compared to a karo khan you know
basically it's the same position
but we have a pawn on e6 and a pawn on
c7 so we have an ideal version of the
french
except it doesn't suck now a3 is a weird
move i don't know why he did this
a3 c3 c3h3 he's wasting a lot of time
making pawn moves
and giving us the ideal setup wait wv
um i hope you're i hope you're sarcastic
i wasn't didn't actually mean any
disrespect to my opponent i didn't mean
to like slow roll him
okay so queen b6 and he goes knight f3
and now of course we win the pawn now
how did i see this well
there's no easy answer here because to
be completely honest with you guys
it's my pattern recognition that kicked
in here
but as i was doing this i remembered a
game that i played
many many years ago where i did
something pretty similar and
that game has sort of stuck with me
because it's a similar type of idea
if i may show you that segment
from the prehistoric era from the
absolute prehistoric era
so yeah this um
this was the k through four nationals in
fourth grade
and um it was 1900 and i used to i
played the night off then
well of course compared uh this was in
houston
so in this position we have a typical
knight or if i was playing a very
underrated player
and we get this position right and
okay so the moment he played rook c1
two things occurred to me at first i was
like man this is bad this is bad because
the rook is x-raying the queen but
x-rays work both ways the other thing to
notice here
is that the queen on f2 it might not
seem significant
but his back rank is weak here right his
king has no escape to the second rank
so i found an idea that was really nice
and he fell right into it
i go rook f to c8 this appears to be a
very pointless move
because of course well i am technically
attacking his pawn
but he can just kick my bishop away with
b3 and then why did i put the rook on c8
it's just staring at the pawn that's
well defended
what did he miss
and this is the nice concept malcolm
very nice bishop takes b3
and after c takes b3 what's the
follow-up
yep exactly you take one rook
then you take the other rook and it's
not checkmate the queen has to block
but when you tally up um when you tally
up
the scores here black is up in exchange
and upon
so this is the kind of idea that that
occurred in this game right using the
fact that a piece is undefended or
poorly defended
and then particularly taking the pawn
with a bishop so it's a sort of pin
right it's not exactly a pin but it
really is a pin
the reason a lot of people i think miss
this
is because when we see a rook x-raying
the queen we just assume that it's good
for the rook that the queen is the one
which is going to be in trouble
but that's not necessarily the case pins
go both ways
you know the rook is is x-raying the
queen but the queen is also x-raying the
rook
and in this case black holds all of the
cards because white can't get rid of his
pawn
even if he wants to whereas black can be
the one to exploit the fact the pawn is
upon us here if that makes sense thank
you uh
the anunna for the four months okay so
bishop takes a3
and so that kind of um
that kind of led to this i'm not saying
it's deep at all i'm not saying it's
it's it's that deep i just think it's
maybe a good way to understand how
the pattern recognition comes into being
um okay
i'm just looking yeah so if we didn't do
this
what how else could we develop our
pieces
well we could play this very very simple
we could play
either rook c8 here preemptively putting
a rook here just in case the file opens
we can play knight g to e7
and then you know get the knight to g6
and in the karu khan you often drop the
bishop back to g6
to get the knight to f5 so many
different things we could do
you could also take the knight
immediately and go knight g7 although i
like this less
you can play bishop d3 so many things
that could be done here
as an alternative all right so of course
uh you would have to check that there's
no discovery as i said
bishop d3 this should be four track
bishop d2 again if we take
then after takes takes queen a4 check he
wins he wins the bishop
um what if you played knight before
instead of retreating the bishop that
knight before allows b takes a3
i know what you're trying to do here but
look more carefully queen takes d3
defense the rook
wait wv can you can you uh express for
for all people replying the stalemate in
the position was very unrealistic
also he still had a pawn move that being
said i feel like playing for a stalemate
in a position where i'm 20 points down
oh you're saying he was disrespectful no
no it's i mean i think he was fine
just for the record as a quick detour
because i think this is a pertinent
topic i know what you're saying
i personally don't think it's that
disrespectful to play until checkmate
i think what is disrespectful one could
argue is taking
all of your time in a position where
you're down you know a bunch of pieces
but
it's within your rights if you want to
make somebody prove it
then you can make somebody prove it and
i don't think people should necessarily
take
personal offense at that i think it can
be a little bit dirty it can be a little
bit
annoying but i wouldn't go so far as to
call it disrespectful
if if that makes sense not that i have a
monopoly on what's respect and what's
not that's just my opinion
okay
yeah letting the clock run out is very
disrespectful i agree
doing it quickly if you're just playing
and trying to lure your opponent into
salemating you that's fine
okay yeah i've people have done that
against me just like take up all their
time i remember when one tournament my
brother was playing
and he was around 1900 he was playing
another 1900 and he was winning
and the guy was playing really quickly
so he had 50 minutes left at the end of
the game but he was totally lost
and he literally gets up on his own move
and he returns 25 minutes later and he's
got a hot dog
and he literally went to like a
restaurant to get food during his move
when he was three moves away from
getting checkmated
so that's crossing the line otherwise
it's fine
okay so bishop d2 knight g to e7 he
castles
which is good tactical recognition again
this is a super typical situation
bishop b5 wins the queen now if you
remember charlie against erob
once did something like this um
so he did it in the wrong order you have
to first take the knight of course
take stakes which should be fine so we
castle rook fu1
and um knight g6
knight g6 essentially
blocking away the bishop right not
allowing the bishop to to do any kind of
shenanigans and
reinforcing the threat of knight takes
d4
h6 would also be possible although it
doesn't necessarily defend against the
check on h7
and he goes h4 which is a mistake
although it's a pretty cool move
my brother is currently 2100 although
he's retired from chess but he's
yeah 2090 i think you can look it up
um and
what should white have done i mean he
should have defended the pawn he should
have defended the pawn
and then we go rook ac yeah he's not bad
we're okay c8
um occupying the open file that's a
great move knight p4 is fine
black is just upon him okay so h4ni
takes
d4 and um
using the 15 second rule i think is a
good way to spot queen f4 right in this
position
many people would look at this and say
ah i'm losing right i can't move the
knight
the line is over but take another 15-20
seconds
just to look for some crazy tactical
resources and i would
advance i would move and even if you're
14 1500 if i asked you
explicitly to look for resources in this
in that position even if you were
visualizing that in your head there
would be a high probability that you
would have seen queen f4
it's a pretty simple position there's
not a lot of pieces left
right and and it's a good thing to do
when you're playing longer games
you're about to abandon the line which
if it works would have been really good
for you
right that's because the stakes are high
if this works for black we've won a
central pawn and that's pretty damn
important
so don't give up on it too quickly don't
give up on lines that could benefit you
if they work
try your best to be resilient and take
an additional 20 30 seconds
before abandoning the line for good
well the 15 second rule is like take 15
seconds
in the position where you're about to
abandon the line
to and allow yourself to look for crazy
resources look at the position with a
different pair of eyes
and one way to do that is to say i'm
assuming
sorry i'm assuming that i have to move
the knight do i actually have to move
the night
right you got to ask yourself these
questions to bring out the creative side
creativity is all about reframing the
process of
finding a move in terms of you know
understanding the position differently
creativity comes when you tell yourself
i don't have to move my knight
i've been assuming that all along but i
don't have to do it
and so then you tell yourself that queen
f4 is far likelier
okay so of course if the queen were
defended he would be able to play h6 g6
that's the whole point
so queen f4 queen for knight f4 and
black his two pawns up
why we can't allow the bishop to take
because okay so let's say
knight f4 right bishop takes h7 king
takes h7 and the queen is lost this is a
classic discovered attack and
winning the queen and this doesn't work
because the rook just takes the knight
can you look at knight 64 before bishop
takes d2 sure
so we have a question about this move
yeah but prime suspect the point is
white takes here
first not quite a form ah oh i see what
you're saying
you say you're saying we have this move
when you're absolutely right
look at that that's phenomenal tactical
vision by
prime suspect 50. you absolutely deserve
a sub
let me gift you a sub i'm gifting you a
sub
that's a great instance of tactical
recognition comparison
understanding how the position has
changed i didn't see that
takes takes queen a4 check and knight to
c6
defending the bishop with the queen and
i think that would have been the best
move i could have taken the pawn
because if bishop takes b4 who can tell
me
do we take on b4 or do we take this
knight first what should we do
are both possible
we have to play knight f3 first of
course we don't want to do this this
time
this wins the queen even though you have
knight c6 it doesn't help because of the
pin
okay so knight f3 first
then queen takes b4 and we're up two
pawns good job again that was awesome
i'm really happy to see that kind of
stuff okay so
queen f4 queen c2 you hit the queen
first
um queen e2 that's good knight e7
and yeah we're just two buns up and uh
and winning here we're winning in this
position but
we have some work left to do so b4 he
advances the pawn he weakens the c3
square so we occupy it with the rook
what if he takes back with the pawn
instead of the queen
wait when oh you're still talking about
this
well that doesn't help right because our
queen is doesn't appear on d4 we just go
queen takes before
right uh it only runs this pawn
structure so back to the game
queen takes d4 h5 queen f4 queen c2
yeah so rook c3 is very simple right
um yeah we should have taken yeah so in
hindsight i would say
a slightly more accurate move would have
been to take his central pawn
because he's essentially stuck right his
bishop is stuck
and if he brings it back we have this
very nasty move we can play rook ac8 now
it's just
marginally better i don't know oh you're
an fm that's awesome though
still okay 97 8 g3 queen g5
rook c3 and the rest is very simple
knight f5 i
i was worried about going here because
of rook a1
and the pawn is hard to defend that's
why he's brought the pawn to b5
so knight f5 is right in time he should
have taken the knight
and gone rook a1 that would have been
the most resilient but
after rook c2 you know we're still
very much dominating we're two pawns up
and we're winning
yeah it's always the fm's nice so knight
takes g3 is very simple
and the game is over boom boom four
pawns up and now he gives the rook but
of course even if he moved his king
we would have taken and either forced to
queen trade or uh checkmated him with a
queen of the rock
yes they do the fm's always see
everything
feed a master and the rest was
the rest was easy okay again if
rook g4 g6 takes takes he plays rook
takes g6 check
and this is already it's winning for
black if you go king h7 as brandon
indicated
but that move has to be spotted this is
actually still
winning for black but why would you play
with fire like that right if
you take the rook then wipe perpetuals
after queen g6
and queen h6
to be cool yeah exactly but this is much
simpler
okay any questions ladies and gentlemen
any questions about this game that was a
very rich
game lots of stuff happened so
don't be afraid to ask questions i'm
not holding anybody up what about rook
c2
when a rook c2
here no but
rook c2 instead of queen takes e5 um
oh you mean rook d2 yeah rook d2 was
fine right to do one the queen
takes and king h8 yeah that was totally
possible maybe even marginally better
but it didn't matter
you can find my shirt at the charlotte
chess center but it's only for the
employees
thank you nema sign productions
oh you're stephen breckenridge oh nice
oh can i i hope i yeah totally yeah yeah
of course
nice steven welcome welcome no you has
public information you can find my
tournament
um nice nice steven good to see you
yeah yeah sorry nobody you can i mean
people can people can find that
tournament and see who i played
i'm sorry if i didn't i didn't didn't do
that deliberately though i accidentally
um i didn't mean to uh to to say your
last name
i hope that's okay well
okay but again you guys can look up my
tournament history and find
the game in the 2007 national so
it's it's kind of public information
sorry about that though um i think he's
okay with it
okay i apologize i really i didn't i
just it was just a i automatically
automatically set set it but yeah steven
beat me in the 2007 nationals
um see stephen if you are okay with me
i'll show i'd show you the game i'll
show the game where you beat me
are you okay with me showing the game
where you beat me
um
he beat me when i was 2100 and steven
was 1900
um and then i lost a 1700 after that
because i was so tilted
yeah so this was a perk by the way this
is a very nice game
this was a very nice game this was in
sacramento
one of my worst tournaments i lost two
games once
to steven and then another game to 1700
so this was a modern
and basically
we got this benoni structure thank you
haircut
got this benoni structure and the
chessler's bless your router this week
and i went after his bishop and this was
this was i think a oh underestimation
of these central pawns because what
happened here is steven goes d5 and i'm
like oh my goodness
because after he takes d5 rook a to d8
very nice move
uh pinning the knight the pawn to the
knight i broke up his pawn structure but
now the knight lands on d4
and things get really hairy takes takes
knight p5
but my pieces are sort of stuck in
mid-air
while steven's pieces are all
centralized he goes a6
if knight d4 then queen c5 forks all
these pieces
this was a classical tournament so i
took here but now the knight is horribly
placed
boom goes the dynamite d3 and b5 now the
knight is x communicated
d2 is a super nice move if queen takes
d5 then d takes c1
and who can spot the move here i'm going
through the game quickly i don't really
want to analyze it in too much detail
but black is a very pretty move here i
remember seeing this and i was like
damn it boom queen a7 check
and he takes d5 and um
b4 is just a this is just a very
beautiful game bishop takes c3 queen d7
now i'm gone down
and i'm getting crushed and the rest was
very simple queen d3 i had to give up
the exchange
peace is flying all around he trades
queens and the rest is a simple matter
of technique i made it a little bit
difficult
but i never was able to uh produce any
real chances
that was a very nice game and obviously
super underrated
and after that yeah i lost a game to a
1700
the round after that so that were my
those were my tournament chances
well done well done
[Music]
you